now an intruder has attacked the husband
of U.S House speaker Nancy Pelosi at the
couple's home in San Francisco Paul
Pelosi is being treated in for injuries
in hospital but is expected to make a
full recovery the alleged attacker is
being held in custody police are
investigating whether there is a
political motive Nancy Pelosi was not at
home at the time
well let's cross over to Washington DC
and speak to DW's Michaela kufner
Michaela what more do we know about this
assault
well we know very little except for the
bare details that in the middle of the
night the attacker managed to get into
the house according to AP which is
citing closed sources through the back
door attacking Paul Pelosi with a hammer
he does not have the kind of security
detail that his wife of course has Nancy
Pelosi as the speaker of the house so
what is unclear is what kind of security
Arrangements were there he was brought
to hospital and according to a statement
by a spokesperson for Nancy Pelosi he is
injured but he's expected to make a full
recovery so the open question is is this
politically motivated we do not have
details about the attacker what his
motivation was or is this plainly crime
but it does come at a time as concerns
are growing here of politically
motivated violence and we also recently
heard a Republican senator Susan Cole
islands of Maine given interviews saying
that she wouldn't be surprised if a
senator got killed so that other levels
of concern here at this very moment with
still very sketchy details
yeah and I think more broadly there
would be other concerns about security
for U.S politicians ahead of the midterm
elections next month
well it really doesn't matter who you
ask on the hill there is an increasing
level of threats extending to individual
Senators we've seen those interviews as
well also we're seeing polling that
shows after that very violent
Insurrection on January 6 2021 that more
and more not just Republicans see
violence as a legitimate way to change
the political course depending on which
poll you cite it's between a quarter and
a third of Americans who believe that
that could be justified in certain
circumstances so you do see a more
preparedness to go beyond simply voicing
your concerns your opinion through the
political processes this is really
hanging like a dark cloud over these
upcoming elections and Donald Trump of
course in the past and just recently
saying that the minority leader Mitch
McConnell when he voted in favor of the
budget of the household continuing
avoiding a government shutdown that he
had a death wish we've seen quite a bit
of rhetoric and just this week and we
saw the conviction of three men who were
plotting to abduct Gretchen vitma a
governor here in the United States so
you can see these as individual
incidents but what it amounts to is a
growing concern that there could be
violence in the run-up and during or
potentially also after the upcoming
midterm elections on November the 8th
all right Michaela kufner reporting for
us in Washington DC thank you so much